ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Recently, the Huberman
Lab hosted a live event
at The Chicago Theater
in Chicago, Illinois.
The event consisted of a
lecture entitled "The Brain Body
Contract" followed by a
question and answer session.
We wanted to make sure that the
question and answer session was
available to
everybody, regardless
of who could attend in person.
I also want to
make sure to thank
the sponsors of that event,
which were AG1 and Eight Sleep.
Eight Sleep makes smart mattress
covers with cooling, heating,
and sleep tracking capacity.
One of the key things to
getting a great night's sleep
is to make sure that the
temperature of your sleeping
environment is
correct, and that's
because in order to fall
and stay deeply asleep,
your body temperature
actually has to drop
by about 1 to 3 degrees.
And in order to wake up feeling
refreshed and energized,
your body temperature
actually has
to increase by about
1 to 3 degrees.
With Eight Sleep, you can
program the temperature
of your sleeping environment
in the beginning, middle,
and end of your night.
It has a number
of other features,
like tracking the amount
of rapid eye movement
and slow wave
sleep that you get,
things that are essential
to really dialing
in the perfect
night's sleep for you.
I've been sleeping on
an Eight Sleep mattress
cover for well
over two years now,
and it has greatly
improved my sleep.
I fall asleep far more quickly,
I wake up far less often
in the middle of the
night, and I wake up
feeling far more
refreshed than I ever
did prior to using an
Eight Sleep mattress cover.
If you'd like to
try Eight Sleep,
you can go to eightsleep.com to
save $150 off their pod three
cover.
Eight Sleep currently
ships to the USA,
Canada, UK, select countries
in the EU, and Australia.
Again, that's
eightsleep.com/huberman.
AG1 is an all in one vitamin
mineral probiotic drink.
I've been taking AG1
since 2012, so I'm
delighted that they
sponsored the live event.
The reason I started
taking AG1, and the reason
I still drink AG1
once or twice a day,
is that it provides all of my
foundational nutritional needs.
That is, it provides
insurance that I
get the proper amounts of those
vitamins, minerals, probiotics
and fiber to ensure optimal
mental health, physical
health, and performance.
If you'd like to try AG1, you
can go to drinkAG1.com/huberman
to claim a special offer.
They're giving away five free
travel packs, plus a year's
supply of vitamin D3 K2.
Again, that's
drinkAG1.com/huberman to claim
that special offer.
And now, without further ado,
the question and answer session
from our live event
at The Chicago
Theater in Chicago, Illinois.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I turn 70 soon.
What is your best advice to keep
my brain healthy in old age?
Terrific question.
The advice I would give to you,
as somebody about to reach 70,
is the same advice
I give to anybody,
which is that, essentially,
all of the things that improve
cardiovascular
health and perfusion
of your bodily tissues are
going to improve functionality
of the brain.
Because, of course, the brain
is a rich consumer of fuel,
requires very good portals
to deliver those fuels,
and the capillaries, micro
capillaries and arteries,
and so forth, need to
be clean and clear.
That's the big one.
This is why I think
the prescription now
is that's generally
accepted, and here I'm
borrowing from my friend
Peter Attia, but about 150,
or maybe as much as 200 minutes
of so-called zone 2 cardio
per week, movement that you
can just barely carry out
a conversation, is
going to be very useful.
One thing that's
often not discussed
is that load bearing
exercise of some sort
is going to be better, provided
your body can tolerate it,
but you should do something
that you can do consistently
over those long durations
without injuring yourself.
But there's a very
interesting literature
about how load bearing
movements actually
generate the
release of hormones,
yes, hormones, from
bone that actually
cross the blood-brain
barrier and may influence
health of neurons in brain
areas such as the hippocampus.
And there, I'm extending from
preclinical data in animals
to humans, but there's
some human data starting
to emerge that that's true.
It's also true, and there's
a wonderful paper out
just today or yesterday
from Dr. Andy Galpin's lab
and collaborators
talking about how
if you look at
cognitive health, it's
highly correlated with things
that relate to strength.
And that is not to say
that you should just
do strength training
exercises but we
know that all people,
truly all people,
should be doing some sort
of resistance training
two or three times per week.
You know, and we know that
grip strength and increasing
asymmetry in grip strength
between the two hands
is one of the indicators
of deficits in control
from the brain out
to the periphery,
and it's correlated
with cognitive decline.
There's also some
interesting data
about how when the feet become
floppy and kind of flaccid
or the lack of ability
to extend one's toes.
I'm still working, I've been
wearing this toe spreader
thing.
Has anyone tried those?
Those hurt.
I broke this foot
a bunch of times.
but I'll tell you when you get
better at spreading your toes,
it's really exciting.
And it's really exciting
for several reasons.
It's really exciting
because there's
more stability in your feet.
You can run and move and do
things better without pain.
But in addition to that,
believe it or not, just as one
of the first things
that they're going
to do when you come
into this world
is scrape the bottom
of your foot and look
for the Babinski reflex,
which is a neural transmission
reflex, as all reflexes
are, but it's testing,
essentially, the health
of the nervous system.
That over time, again,
there are many correlates
of dementia, many, many
correlates of dementia,
but an inability to finely
control the extremities
is certainly one of them.
So strength training,
cardiovascular training, these
are kind of stereotyped
answers for your question
and, yet, those are
really the prime movers
against cardiovascular and
cerebrovascular disease.
And then, of course,
I'd be remiss
if I didn't throw in something
that was a little bit more
edgy because that's what I do.
There are interesting
data about the use
of drugs to increase
acetylcholine transmission,
right?
I mean, I was visiting a
Nobel Prize winner at Columbia
to learn about his incredible
work some years ago
and saw that he chewed
no fewer than five pieces
of Nicorette gum, something
I don't recommend,
during this short meeting.
And I said, what
is this all about?
And he said, well, you
know, I don't smoke anymore
because I don't
want lung cancer.
But he said nicotine
is protective against
Parkinson's and Alzheimer's.
I was like, how can that be?
And he said, well, you know,
decreases in neuromodulation,
dopamine, acetylcholine
correlated
with cognitive decline,
keeping your brain sharp,
and so on and so forth.
So I'm not encouraging
people to take nicotine.
It increases blood
pressure, vasoconstriction,
but it's an interesting
consideration
some of the emerging cholinergic
and dopaminergic drugs are ways
to increase acetylcholine
and dopamine
are certainly intriguing.
And I won't tell you
who that person is
but his name is Richard Axel.
Next question.
Yeah.
How can I optimize sleep
while working 24/7 hour
shifts as a firefighter,
24 hours on 48 hours off?
OK.
And this probably also
pertains to new parents,
and it probably also
pertains to anyone
that's going through a
particularly stressful time,
where you're micro waking
throughout the night, so not
just firefighters.
So what do we know?
We know, based on
really good data,
that shift work is bad for us.
It's just bad.
We're a diurnal species.
We're not nocturnal.
But thank you, thank you,
thank you, shift workers,
because you essentially
keep us all safe
and make the world go round.
And so we need you, and
we want you healthy.
So one of the main
things is that you
can make sure that you stay on
the same sleep-wake schedule,
excuse me, for at
least two weeks.
It's the swing shift
that's really the worst.
You can tell your
boss I said that.
And if they won't
agree, and you're
doing this 24 hour
on 24 hour off,
there are a couple of things
that are really important.
First of all, the main way to
wake up your nervous system,
even though it might not
feel like a triple espresso
is going to be that light
exposure to the eyes.
And if you can't
get it from sunlight
is going to be from any
bright, artificial light.
I'm not a huge proponent
of the daylight simulators.
They're very expensive.
You can simply buy a 900 lux
led far more inexpensively.
I don't have any
relationship to any company
that sells these but you
can find them on Amazon
or wherever you happen to
prefer to purchase things.
Or you can just get really
close to a bright light.
Anytime you're
trying to wake up,
even if you don't feel
that it helps you wake up
very much, mostly
for the melatonin
suppression, because
bright light will very
acutely suppress melatonin.
And then the real
question from shiftworkers
always seems to be,
should I catch up on sleep
or is that going
to be problematic?
Should I just stay up
into the next cycle?
And the answer there is
a little bit nuanced,
but the best answer I
can give across the board
is, if this is a
pattern that you're
going to be in regularly,
over say months or years,
then get whatever sleep you can.
Get whatever sleep you can.
If it's something that you're
doing somewhat acutely,
like you're traveling to
Europe and you're just
going to force yourself to
stay up a day and a half
then, in that case,
I would say, no need
to get the maximum
amount of sleep.
Just try and stay with
the local schedule.
We have an entire
episode about shift work
that somehow maybe didn't
get as much recognition
as it should have
for shift workers,
and we'll try and get
it out in better form.
We don't always succeed
in top carding things
in a way that gets them
out to the most people.
One thing I will say
is an opportunity
to announce that our
website, hubermanlab.com, is
completely revamped so
it's highly searchable.
It will take you to
exact timestamps,
and now you can segregate out
timestamps from newsletters,
from all this stuff.
So thanks to a lot of
effort by my amazing team,
you can now navigate that
site to real precision.
So if you want to say
ADHD, Adderall, kids, yes,
no, for instance,
it will take you
to precise timestamps that
will address those issues.
Next question, please.
How does hypnosis therapy work?
Well, this is a very
interesting topic to me
because my colleague,
Associate Chair of Psychiatry
at Stanford, David Spiegel,
is a world expert in hypnosis
and its neural
underpinnings and its use
for clinical applications.
His father was a hypnotist,
also a psychiatrist.
And when people hear hypnotism,
they think of stage hypnotism
and being up on stage and
doing things you don't want to
in front of other people.
But really, it's
when we're talking
about clinical
applications or wellness
applications of
hypnosis, we're talking
about self-directed hypnosis.
I really wish there
was a better name,
because I don't think
hypnosis is going
to advance very far as a field,
frankly, because everyone
thinks hypnosis.
And it would be
like if psychedelics
were just called drugs, right?
We were taught in the
80s that drugs are bad,
and that your brain on
drugs looks like an omelet,
and that's bad.
And if you like omelets,
they're still bad.
And drugs of abuse are bad.
And, actually, I hope
we can talk briefly
about psychedelics
at some point,
because I do think
there's a little bit
of a runaway train around the
topic of psychedelics now.
I think we need to be
very careful how we
approach that entire landscape.
But hypnosis essentially
works by allowing someone
to place their own brain
into this very unique state.
Earlier, we were talking
about neuroplasticity,
and we talked about the fact
that neuroplasticity involves
intense focus followed by deep
rest in the form of deep sleep
or non-sleep deep rest, maybe
even Rick Rubining it and just
kind of like laying there.
Hypnosis is different
because hypnosis
is a state in which your
focus is very narrow,
the context is very narrow,
but you're very, very relaxed.
So maybe the Rubin example of
being brain active and body
very still is a bit more
like hypnosis, to be fair.
Why would it be the case that
David Spiegel and his dad
have literally a tool that is
approved by the Psychiatric
Association, the major American
Psychiatric Association,
where they can figure
out how hypnotizable
you are by having look
up and try and close
your eyelids while
continuing to look up,
the so-called Spiegel
eye roll test.
Sounds pretty wacky, right?
This is like TikTok level wacky.
Well, the reason is you
have cranial nerves,
so they sit more or less
near your neck, that
allow you to direct your
focus, your eyes, upward,
and then you have cranial nerves
that have your eyes go down
and the ones that the cranial
nerves that drive your eyes up
are associated with
alertness and eyes open.
No surprise.
And the cranial nerves
that are associated
with pointing your eyes down
and closing your eyelids
are associated with, what,
with drowsiness, sleep,
and lack of alertness.
There's sort of a push-pull in
the autonomic nervous system.
And Spiegel, Spiegel's
daddy and him,
figured out, because
they're geniuses,
that if somebody
can maintain upward
gaze while closing their
eyelids, two things happen.
One, you'll see the
whites of their eyes,
and it's pretty creepy.
Two, that means they're
highly hypnotizable,
because that is a reflection
of the probability
that they can enter a
brain state in which they
are both very awake
and very relaxed.
Pretty cool.
Now, if that sounds
kind of wacky,
because you're just
looking at the periphery,
keep in mind, that one
of the primary entry
points for diagnosing concussion
is to shine a light in one eye
and have that pupil
constrict and then
see whether or not the
other pupil constricts,
the so-called consensual
pupillary reflex.
Although, technically,
and I've been bothered
by this from day
one, it should be
called the non-consensual
pupil reflex,
because the other eye doesn't
have a choice if everything's
working.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
In any case, if you have
a hard hit to the head,
you'll see that you shine
light in one eye, the pupil
constricts, and the other
one stays really dilated.
And then you go, OK, get this
person to the emergency room
because there's been a
severing of the connections
between the two
sides of the brain.
So looking in the
eyes and trying
to deduce what might be
happening more centrally
within the caverns of
the skull and the brain
is not a new thing.
It is a primary diagnostic
tool in neurology.
It's also how your parents
knew that you were taking drugs
when you came in the door
because your pupils were
like that big, and that
reflects a difference
in autonomic arousal.
And, basically, stimulants,
as, most dilate their pupils.
This is also why the story
about belladonna, people
intentionally
dilating their pupils
to trick people into
thinking that they
were attracted to them.
I've thought about
this one a lot, too.
It's like not a precursor
to good relationship.
It's like someone's
using their physiology
to pretend that
they're attracted
so the other person thinks that
they're attracted so that they
might become attracted.
Anyway, it's a recipe for
failure, almost as bad
as most of the dating apps.
Well, I wouldn't know.
I'm not one them,
but from what I hear.
OK.
So where were we?
Hypnosis.
When you are in a state
of elevated attention
but very relaxed, guess
what, neuroplasticity
occurs much faster
because you're essentially
marrying the two states
that are normally divorced,
which are heightened
levels of attention
first and then deep rest.
You're essentially putting the
nervous system into a more,
I wouldn't call it hypoplastic
state, but a more plastic
state.
And for people that are
highly hypnotizable,
the success rates at, for
instance, smoking cessation,
pain relief, are
pretty impressive.
Spiegel Lab has published
a number of these.
So I think self hypnosis
is a very interesting tool.
I just hope that
they rename it so
that it stands a chance
of getting off the ground.
I mean, one of the
things that you
learn as a public
facing educator
is that what things are
called has a great impact on
whether or not they achieve
any kind of use in the world.
Hence, why I decided to swallow
the difficult pill of partially
renaming yoga nidra as
non-sleep deep rest.
I don't like to do that.
Yoga nidra has more
than 1,000 year history.
But when people hear yoga
nidra, unless they are very open
minded, they hear magic carpet.
They hear levitation,
and it's unfortunate,
and that's not how I feel.
But for years, I talked about
yoga nidra, it's so cool.
It's like a sleep state but
it's-- they're like, yeah,
like yoga nidra.
OK.
But if you come from a culture
where that's discussed,
they're all about it.
And so non-sleep deep rest, you
know, I felt like, all right,
leave my name out of it.
You know, I'll be
dead eventually.
I mean, I'm in this
line of advisors, right?
I'm like approaching 50.
I'm like, I'm winning
in my lineage.
But should I be fortunate enough
to live past bullet cancer
or car crash far enough, then
NSDR hopefully will persist,
and I don't need a piece of it.
It's just the hope
is that people
will learn to put themselves
into brain states that
can be adaptive for
them so it'd be nice
if someone could come up with
something other than hypnosis.
I think Spiegel would agree.
Super interested in
psychedelics as medicine
to be done with somebody
with experience.
Worried about unlocking
mental health conditions.
Yeah.
You should be.
What does the research say,
and what are your thoughts?
OK.
Barbed wire question,
we like that.
Psychedelics, well, let's
just back up a little bit
and acknowledge one
thing that's more
important than
psychedelics or anything
else when it comes to
rewiring the brain, which
is that, ultimately, rewiring
of the brain is about shifts
in neuromodulators, dopamine,
serotonin, epinephrine,
norepinephrine, acetylcholine.
And it's no coincidence that
SSRIs, Selective Serotonin
Reuptake Inhibitors, have
been one of the major entry
points for attempts to
treat things like depression
over the last 20-30
years or more.
When I was in college, that's
when the book Listening
to Prozac came out.
But prior to that,
there's a long history
of drugs, prescription
drugs, in that case,
to change levels
of neuromodulators,
like serotonin or
acetylcholine or dopamine,
in an attempt to cure
or treat a disease.
But keep in mind, despite
the varied success of SSRIs,
a topic unto itself, that
there's a strong belief,
and there has been
for a long time, that,
if SSRIs worked it wasn't
because the depressed brain is
deficient in
serotonin, but rather
because increasing serotonin
offered the opportunity
to increase neuroplasticity.
So there's a different
way of thinking about it,
and that's a segue for saying
that when you say psychedelics,
that's a broad
category of drugs.
Nowadays, people even
lump ketamine into that.
Although, technically,
it's not a psychedelic.
But the sort of
classic, if you will,
psychedelics are LSD,
Lysergic Acid Diethylamide,
and psilocybin, aka mushrooms.
Although, it comes in
other sources, as well.
The major effect
of psilocybin is
to stimulate a
particular serotonin
receptor which has elevated
density in particular brain
areas.
And indeed, there are many
recent clinical trials, many,
let's say 12 to 20 good
sized clinical trials done
in diverse locations on the
planet, many at Johns Hopkins
and UCSF, some in Switzerland,
showing that enhancing,
and here you'll notice I'm
using the mechanistic language,
enhancing the transmission
of the release of serotonin
and activating particular
serotonin receptors
leads to an opportunity for
more, what, neuroplasticity.
Now, I say it that way not
to add a bunch of word soup
but because the real
question is whether or not
the experience
that one has while
under the influence
of psychedelics
is critical to the
clinical outcome.
Or a growing idea,
just as a hypothesis,
I think is equally
interesting is
that it's the serotonin itself
and that the things you see,
the things you hear, the
things you experience
are not relevant.
Now, I have some experience
with psychedelics.
I had a bad time on
psychedelics as a teenager.
I was also pretty wayward youth.
But I've had a bad trip on LSD.
For years, I was scared
that people were going
to dose me with LSD after that.
It was so bad.
I think across the board, we
can say, kids doing psychedelics
just seems like a bad idea.
Their brains are
already hypoplastic.
If you have a predisposition
to bipolar type
issues or schizophrenia, it
can exacerbate those issues.
And, certainly, if you
don't have adequate support,
in the form of somebody that can
guide you through the sessions,
as well as the
presessions, which are not
done with psychedelics, as well
as the so-called integration
afterwards, it can be a
really slippery slope.
I know examples of
people really suffering
in the aftermath of
psychedelic journeys.
Now, there are a few
interesting points, as well,
and it wouldn't be fair if
I didn't say that several,
if not many,
individuals who have
had so-called treatment
resistant depression, at least
in these clinical
trials, have reported
feeling far better after
psilocybin therapy,
but that psilocybin therapy was
done with several presessions,
then the psychedelic sessions
then several after sessions.
And it's not always the case
that things turn out well.
So I think it's early days.
What is interesting,
and I think important,
is to recognize that psilocybin
and the structure of psilocybin
is very similar to serotonin
itself, very similar,
but it activates
particular receptors.
A lot of people don't realize
how similar to serotonin it is,
and that microdosing
psilocybin, I
should say the
data on microdosing
psilocybin, something
that's increasingly popular,
is not particularly compelling.
It's not clear what it does.
It's not clear if
it's of any use.
And I think the danger here is
that we end up in a situation
as we did with,
frankly, with cannabis.
And, by the way,
I'm not somebody
who demonizes cannabis.
I think it has its uses
for certain people,
but very high THC
concentration cannabis
can be a problem, especially
with people that have
a predisposition to psychosis.
And anyone that tells you
that cannabis isn't addictive,
just say, great, don't
smoke weed for a week.
Let's see how you do.
Yeah.
And let's go on a
plane trip together.
And how are you sleeping?
And so I think the chronic
cannabis users are starting
to take note of some of
the issues it causes but,
again, there are some
clinical applications.
Now, when it comes to the
high speed train psychedelics,
like DMT, that's far less
data available there.
And then MDMA,
assisted psychotherapy
for the treatment
of PTSD, there,
the data I think
are more robust,
and I think we're likely
to see legalization
or at least decriminalization
in the next few years.
But keep in mind that MDMA is
methylenedioxymethamphetamine.
So for people that like
dopaminergic states,
it's a particularly
compelling state
to be in, so much so that they
could overindulge in MDMA,
and then there's the
issues of purity,
and I could do a five hour
podcast on this right now.
So I think the important point
is approach with caution.
Kids, absolutely not.
And I think it's an exciting
landscape, very exciting,
and whereas a
discussion like the one
we just had would have gotten
me fired a few years ago.
I mean, Stanford has
big programs now,
a lot of philanthropy,
federal grants,
and many laboratories focused
on the study of psychedelics.
So I would say stay tuned.
But keep in mind that increasing
neuromodulator levels very
acutely, whether or not it's
with a prescription drug
or whether or not it's
with psychedelics,
is really what lies at
the heart of the recovery,
the potential
recovery, I should say,
or the negative
effects that happen
to occur in anyone that embarks
on the psychedelic journey.
Do people who meditate and
need less sleep than people who
don't?
Oh, that's interesting.
Well, we know that from a study
by Wendy Suzuki, who I believe,
if NYU made the
right choice, and I
think they did is, now the Dean
of Arts and Sciences at NYU.
She ran a memory
lab for a long time.
She has data showing
that even 10, I
think it's 13, but as little
as 10 minutes of meditation,
so it'll be sitting
still, breathing,
focusing on your breathing,
directing one's attention
to third eye center, et cetera.
We don't have a third eye.
The pineal is thought
to be the third eye.
But I don't know
why people say it's
a light sensitive
tissue deep in the brain
but maybe that's why they
call it the third eye.
But, in any case,
that type of practice
has been shown to increase
memory focus, aka learning,
but there's some
interesting footnotes
in those papers, which
point to the fact
that when people meditate too
close to bedtime, oftentimes,
they have trouble sleeping
because, basically, meditation
is a focusing exercise.
It's a perceptual exercise.
I don't think of meditation
is anything mystical.
It's a self-directed shift
in your perception to,
what, to your interoception,
to your internal state,
as opposed to anything beyond
the confines of your skin.
There's nothing
mystical about that.
And then, in that
state, your brain
starts to generate
patterns of activity that
are distinct from
when you're sharing
your attention between
what's going on internally
and what's happening
out in the world, right?
I think we need to
demystify what people
have cloaked as mystical.
And when I say
cloaked, I don't think
that the people that have
meditated for thousands
of years thought that there
was anything mystical about it
but, sometimes,
what we experience
there can feel mystical.
So if you have
trouble sleeping, I
recommend doing some sort of
non-sleep deep rest practice,
like NSDR, aka yoga nidra.
Although, those are different.
NSDR generally lacks
the intention piece.
And the ones that I've
put into the world,
we've stripped away
the intentions,
and we've stripped away any kind
of language that would make you
think that there
was some sort of,
let's just say, like
cultural aspect to it,
which, again, is admittedly
a bit unfair to the origin
practice of yoga nidra.
But the problem, again,
is that in yoga nidra,
you're going to be doing
intentions and hearing
language that for
some people, not all,
might divorce you from
the wish to do it.
In any case, non-sleep deep
rest done at any time of day,
but especially if
you fall asleep
in the middle of
the night, is going
to be useful for helping
you fall back asleep.
Whereas meditation,
again, is going
to enhance your level of focus.
So I don't think
it's a good practice
if you have trouble sleeping.
Now, to finally answer your
question, if you meditate,
can you afford to sleep less?
My friend, Matt
Walker, would say no.
However, many of us can't
sleep as much as we want to,
and many of us are not like
Matt, where we can wake up
without an alarm clock.
I'll just keep
sleeping and sleeping,
unless I went to
bed at like 8:00.
This is actually interesting.
There's an asymmetry
to your sleep needs.
If you go to bed,
remember that old adage,
every hour before midnight
is worth two after?
Well, it turns out
that for people
that are meant to be early
risers, going to bed at 8:00,
you'll wake up at 3:00
or 4:00 feeling great.
You go to bed at
11:00, you feel groggy,
and there are good
reasons to explain that.
But Matt would say that
need your sleep, period.
I'm more of the camp, based
on my read of the data,
And, yes, we are allowed to
disagree and still be friends.
It's allowed.
In fact, Matt's going
to do a series on sleep
with our podcast,
even though he has
a terrific podcast of his
own, where we will maybe
debate a little bit of this,
that there are ways that you
can at least replace the
feeling of wakefulness
that you would have lost
if you don't sleep enough.
And for me, really,
that's why NSDR
became such an attractive tool
to do for 10 or 30 minutes each
morning if I didn't sleep
enough the night before.
I first learned
about yoga nidra,
actually at addiction recovery
center, trauma recovery center
in Florida in 2017.
I have a friend, a super
talented trauma therapist,
who also treats addiction, that
I've sent many, many people to,
and he has this kind of
seemingly like wizard ability
to get people who have been
addicts to not be addicts.
And one of the tools he uses
is yoga nidra every morning
for 30 minutes, and
eventually an hour,
which seems like
a lot, but then he
also has these people wake
up very early, maybe an hour
before they would
normally wake up, and go
into that liminal state
between sleep and wakefulness.
Now, my experience is that 10 to
20 minutes of NSDR, yoga nidra,
is sufficient to
offset some sleep loss
and allow at least
me to function,
and many people report the same.
We have a study going with the
Sleep Laboratory at Stanford
to explore this in more depth.
And what I can tell
you, because I'm
involved in some
of this work, is
that there are several military
units, because they have
no opportunity to get sleep
because they're working,
that have to rely
on tools like this
in order to be able to function
at their highest level.
And I'm sure they will
tell you, as I will,
that they'd prefer to get
8 to 10 hours of sleep.
But, guess what,
they can't, and so I
think that's the important
takeaway is that we don't get
to pick how much we
sleep, unless you're
going to be completely neurotic
about your sleep hygiene, which
makes you kind of a less
interesting person in life,
is what I'm told.
Going to bed at 8:00 is great
like some or most of the time
but you got to stay up
every once in a while.
I mean, after they released
"Chimp Empire" on Netflix,
I discovered that NSDR
is a very valuable tool.
And by the way, "Chimp
Empire" and "Succession"
have a lot of parallels.
And if you watch one, I
interleave "Chimp Empire",
"Succession", "Chimp
Empire", "Succession".
And you start to realize, like,
whoa, like were pretty similar.
And then you look at the
world differently, I promise.
Your podcast has
positively changed
the lives of so many
people, including me,
how has it changed your life?
OK.
I wasn't expecting that one.
Thank you, Samantha.
Well, first of all, I mean,
as this little 11-year-old
told me.
I mean, this is essentially
what I've done my whole life.
I'm a fairly private person.
Believe it or not, I'm
pretty introverted.
I spend a lot of time alone, and
I think that's required for me.
I basically have four modes.
Four modes.
One, I'm either readying
myself through sleep and NSDR
to do one of the
other three modes,
maybe there's a fifth mode, or
I'm in one of these other three
modes, which is I'm either
foraging for information,
organizing that information,
or dispersing that information,
or getting ready to
do it all over again.
And then, there's this
relaxation vacation thing
that they keep telling me about.
But then I went to
Italy, and then like Rick
and I like just hung out there,
and it didn't feel like work.
I also discovered some
really great podcasts.
I don't know, I think
one of the coolest
podcasts out there if you like
rock and roll, which I love,
is A History of 500 Songs by
Andrew Hickey's podcast on rock
and roll.
I like the nerdy podcasts.
It's like a graduate or an
education in rock and roll.
It's so cool.
And you'll learn a lot
about music and history
and the mobs involved
and all that stuff.
And from what I was told, like
Al Capone used to sit there,
right?
His exit was there, you
know, so it was weird.
Right?
And then he died of
syphilis, and like
so I don't know how I
feel about all that,
but they told me that.
So I think the podcast has been
wonderful as an opportunity
to share things that I love.
If I had my way, it
would be more like this,
although more of a
dialogue, frankly.
It's changed my understanding
of what the world is like.
I certainly get critique,
and that's good.
But, again, I was
raised by iconoclasts,
and particularly my postdoc
advisor, Ben Barrus,
who unfortunately,
as I mentioned,
is dead because
I worked for him.
But he really encouraged
all of us in his lab.
And often, we were
very close friends.
I spent the last year
of his life recording
interview with him.
There's actually a documentary
coming out about Ben,
and then I'm going to release
the audio interviews with Ben,
which he approved, by the way.
And you'll get to realize that
the history of what you see
is often not what the dead
person really did or said.
It's going to be
fun, so I can't wait
till they release
this documentary,
and then Ben gets to have
his voice infused in it.
And it'll be a cool documentary.
But, as some of you know, that
what appears to be and what was
and the historical
narrative is not necessarily
what really happened,
but that's just life.
So I suppose the short answer
is that I feel very honored
with the opportunity.
Very, very honored.
And it's a challenge at times.
I suppose the major
challenges are
when things are taken out of
context, like little clips,
and things of that sort.
Being misunderstood
doesn't feel good.
But look, at the
end of the day, I
feel like the luckiest
person in the world
because I get to spend
my time learning.
So it's either I'm
foraging, I'm organizing
or I'm dispersing
information that I also want
and that I find
incredibly useful.
Or if not that, then certainly
informative and, at times,
enchanting as well.
So I try and focus
on the positive,
and I have a number of
practices that help me do that.
And I am somebody who
engages on social media.
I'm not a post and
ghost kind of person.
I want to understand.
I think that cuttlefish
are super interesting,
but human beings are
super interesting too.
And I have a strong
drive for mastery,
but also I do have a
strong sense of justice,
and that can be
problematic at times.
I define justice as feeling
like there's something
for us to do about something.
Like seeing something
that upsets us
or that excites us
is great, but then
if you have a strong
sense of justice,
you feel like there's something
you need to do about it,
and not everybody feels that.
And then, of course, a
desire to understand.
And I think, for reasons
very personal to me,
that relate mostly
to just having
a kind of incredible array
of experiences in life,
many of which were like
shocking, disturbing, exciting,
enchanting that I
want to understand.
And so it's changed things,
but it's like, I don't know,
I got one truck, one watch.
Which is not to say that I
don't care about having things.
There are a few
things I really love,
but mostly, like I'm just
thinking about the podcast
we got to record
on Monday which is
about willpower and tenacity.
And if I don't stop myself,
I'll give it right now.
So what do you feel
is the next big thing
to come to the forefront
in the health space?
Thanks for this question.
One is non-protein amino acids.
I love these debates
online because I know
that there's something there.
It's so cool because I grew
up in seeing these debates,
and you know there's
something interesting there
because people are
debating about it.
But the debate isn't
what's interesting.
It's almost always
the thing that people
aren't talking about that's
sure to surface at some point.
And right now, there's.
This obsession with like
seed oils it's like seed oil.
Seed oils.
And I can't demonize seed oils.
All the data say that
if you separate out
their caloric load, there's
nothing inherently bad
about seed oils, and et cetera.
I don't know.
It's still an
emerging literature.
But there was a scientist at
Stanford, Ed Rubenstein, who
passed away at a ripe old age,
a brilliant scientist, who
talked about, and I had
a lot of discussions
with when I was a postdoc,
about non-protein amino acids.
It turns out his son is
a neuroscientist at UCSF.
His other son is a
physician at UCSF.
So it's another one of these
low performing families.
And all wonderful people.
And you know, Ed had data
that unlike a lot of animals,
like birds, there are
certain amino acids, which
are non-protein
amino acids, that
exist in fairly high
density in seeds and nuts,
which is not to say that
seeds and nuts are bad.
I had almonds this
evening, so please.
But non-protein amino
acids are similar enough
to mammalian protein amino
acids that if they are consumed
in abundance, and
perhaps especially
in liquid form, that
they may, again, may,
because this is
about the future.
This isn't about what we know.
This is about where
I think there's
interest and growing interest.
They may be able to incorporate
into certain proteins
of our tissues of our
body that potentially Ed
thought could lead to
misfolding of those proteins
and may explain certain
forms of neurodegeneration
and other neurocognitive
challenges.
So I think non-protein
amino acids are going
to be an important discussion.
Now, there are lots of
non protein amino acids
that don't come
from foods, but I
think the discussion around non
protein amino acids from foods
is going to be very interesting.
So that's one area.
The other area, and perhaps you
picked up on this a little bit
tonight, is that I like the nuts
and boltsy stuff around stress,
neuroplasticity.
But the high level stuff,
I think the relationship
between structured
thought, abstract thought,
I'm not interested in
the free will discussion.
I just feel like
that's a career ender.
I'm friends with
Robert Sapolsky,
and he's got a great
book coming out
about this called
"Determined", so he obviously
doesn't believe in free will.
But he's far smarter
than I ever could be.
And it just feels like,
I don't know that there's
an endpoint with that one.
But if anyone could
find, it would be Robert.
He's oh so smart.
But I think that the higher
level stuff, creativity,
abstract reasoning and
thought, defining and better
understanding the
different states
that we can go into in waking.
And I confess, without a hint
of sheepishness about it,
that I also think the
notion of spirituality
and the belief in
things that are
beyond our current and
conscious understanding
is super interesting.
I think that as a species we've
been challenged and conflicted
from go, at least that's what
the historical scripture tells
us, and that it's sort of
inherent to our experience
that life is challenging and
perplexing and also wonderful.
And so I think a
better understanding
of how to navigate all that, I
mean, this stuff in our skulls,
except for the eyes,
which, by the way,
are your two pieces
of brain that are not
in your skull, the retinas.
I have to point that out.
You know, it's tricky, and we're
trying to use that very tissue
to understand it.
And so I'm intrigued
by the possibility
that there are certain aspects
of self that maybe are not
intended to be explored
because they are not really
of us, right?
Brains interacting
with one another
is an interesting
area, certainly
for scientific
exploration, but I'm
fascinated by and excited
about the possibility
that, at some point, our
species will both understand
and the mechanics
of our emotions,
mechanics of our thought
process, creativity, and so on,
but that we will also
allow room for the stuff
that we can't explain with
science and to allow room
for that in our life
experience because I also
believe that can be powerful.
And while understanding
things in great detail
and putting mechanism
and utility around that
and applying that
is wonderful, it's
the stuff of my life,
which is obvious,
I also think that there's
great value in not
trying to control and
understand everything
and enjoying the
mystery of things that
are clearly greater than us.
[APPLAUSE]
How do you balance
having fun with having
such a rich knowledge and
passion in neuroscience
and optimization?
Fun.
People ask me, like
what do you do for fun?
I think people think I
do all the protocols.
It's like, sure, I get my
sunlight, I drink my water.
I do.
I do them.
But fun, I like learning.
I like learning.
I do enjoy physical movement.
For me, OK, so like for
me, it's the little things.
I don't know, maybe I'm weird.
Certainly, I've been told that.
The other day, there was a
frog in my swimming pool,
and he was just like
sitting there like.
And I just like spent some time
looking at him back and forth,
and then I had all sorts of
ideas about what's he doing?
And what's he thinking?
And then I was thinking
how Oliver Sacks used
to spend time imagining
experiencing life as a bat
through only echolocation.
He talked about this.
And I thought, and
why would he do that?
Right?
And that's kind of cute.
He's like delightful
old man, right?
He had a 600 pounds free weight
squat, won the state California
squatting championship but also
liked pretending he was a bat.
He's a weird dude.
Did methamphetamines,
raced motorcycles,
hung out with movie stars, but
then also was like a recluse
and liked rocks.
OK, that's a weird scientist.
Been around a lot of those.
But in discussions with
people that knew him,
I mean, that exercise of like
seeing something he thought
was cool like a bat allowed
him to also use theory of mind
to kind of think,
what would it be
like to have locked
in syndrome and only
be able to blink your
eyes to communicate?
And gave him an incredible
compassion and sensitivity
for other people that
then he transmuted
into the form of
these wonderful books.
So for me, fun is really
about doing the things
that I do
systematically each day,
but then when
something excites me.
I know that feeling.
I know it physically in my body.
And to just follow that
trail like a weirdo, right?
Like a weirdo, just
like Barrus was weird
and Barbara Chapman was weird.
And like, I think
everybody's a little weird
if you allow yourself to
just see the things that you
think are really cool.
And there are a bunch
of things that I
think are really
cool that enchant me
that a bunch of other
people love too.
And I know that because I see
we're all watching that video
or something like that.
But I think for me,
fun is in the practice
of trying to stay open to
like the little things.
The little things that
kids say are always
delightful because
they're not filtering
through all the bullshit
that we filter our life
experience through.
But also just, yeah, I
like reading and learning,
exercising.
I mean, I like to think I'm
not a very wooden person.
But, at the same time, I mean,
I didn't see the "Barbie" movie.
No disrespect to Barbie.
I go to movies.
I do that kind of thing.
I don't know what
else is there to do?
At some point, you know,
what else is there to do?
Anyway, I mean, I delight
in certain things,
as you now know
far too much about.
But fun is a relative term.
That was a hard question.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING & APPLAUDING]
Thank you.
Thanks for the pass.
Thanks for that.
Do you believe time changes
due to daylight savings
time is worth a potential
loss of productivity?
Daylight saving
time is anti-health.
OK, this is where I'll
get like, it's just dumb.
It's just dumb.
It's just so dumb.
It makes no sense.
I mean, the director of
the Chronobiology Unit
at the National Institutes of
Mental Health, my good friend,
long time friend and brilliant
scientist, Samer Hattar,
will tell you,
it's a stupid idea.
It's anti-biology.
And increased car crashes,
increase heart attacks,
increased depression.
Kids don't like to
wake up early anyway.
Parents don't like
to wake up early,
especially with kids that
don't like wake up early.
It makes no sense.
And then there are
all these arguments
about is really about
trying to truncate the late,
you want more light in the
evening so there's less crime.
Like, that's totally
unsubstantiated.
Like, completely
So the daylight savings
thing is just stupid.
Basically, try and get as
much light in your eyes,
ideally from sunlight
early in the day.
And, by the way, if you're
worried about cataract,
that's a serious concern.
After all, I have an
appointment in ophthalmology.
Cataract, macular degeneration.
But guess what, the chair of
ophthalmology from Stanford
when he came on the
podcast verified this.
When the sun is low
in the sky, you're
not really at risk of that.
So when the sun is
overhead and you're
like beaming in your
eyes, like trying to get,
yeah, it's a problem,
but we're talking
about viewing low solar
angle sunlight in the morning
and in the evening.
And if there's
clouds, do it anyway.
In fact, do it longer.
And if you can't do that,
look at some artificial light
inside.
Daylight savings,
it's just stupid.
You know, what happens here
is as the night goes on,
the amount of GABA in my
brain starts to diminish,
and I just kind of
go to short form.
We've thought about podcasting
in the middle of the night.
That's why when I went on Lex's
podcast recently, the more
recent one, he did it at 8:00
o'clock at night, and he cried.
He made me cry.
He didn't cry.
I was so tired,
and I can't think,
and then he asked
me about my dog,
and I'm talking about the dog.
So his goal was
to get me to cry.
We have this
friendship, you know.
No, he's delightful.
What should I as a
19-year-old college student
be doing to maximize the years
of neuroplasticity I have left?
I get this question,
I'm like, oh, man.
It's such a great question.
Rhys, I'm assuming, yeah.
I don't know who you are,
Rhys, or what you're doing,
but you're 19.
So the cool thing is,
your brain is hypoplastic.
Life is a psychedelic
experience without psychedelics.
Gosh, people always
say, like, if you
could go back to your
19-year-old self,
what would you do?
And that's a tricky one.
There are movies
about that, right?
You know, I would
definitely worry less.
Yeah.
I would worry less.
I would have more fun.
I would certainly,
listen, I started
latching on to practices and
the understanding of science
as a way, for me it was
kind of like my world
felt very unstable.
And for me, it
brought stability.
But you want to avoid rigidity.
So do you want to be the one
19-year-old who's like, oh,
got to get to sleep.
You know, I got to go back
to bed at 8:30 at night.
Enjoy life.
But I would say, when you're
19, learn how you learn.
Learn how to focus.
Learn how to rest.
Basically, you can
stress and focus
as much as you want as long
as you can still fall asleep
at night and sleep well and
fall back asleep if you wake up.
We hear stress is bad, stress
is good, stress is bad,
stress is good.
Stress is bad unless
you're getting
enough sleep, in
which case, stress is
called learning in life.
Now, obviously, don't
do anything dangerous.
Avoid psychological
and physical danger.
But I think as a 19-year-old,
I mean my direct advice would
have some cardiovascular
activity you like,
have some resistance training
activity you like, develop
some sort of self awareness
practice like journaling.
It could be meditation.
Surround yourself with
people that you like.
Avoid people you don't like.
I mean, it sounds so
straightforward but then
we can all look into
our personal histories
and be like, wow, I spent
all this time trying
to resolve this thing that,
clearly, you didn't like them.
It's simple.
You didn't like them.
They weren't into
cuttlefish or ferrets.
You didn't like them.
Wasn't your kind
of person, right?
And that's not a box you can
check on the dating apps,
they tell me, right?
The ferret thing, I think
it'd be very, very, very
small subset of people.
I think the know
thyself thing is huge.
Learn to tap into that
early feeling of like this
feels right.
This doesn't feel right.
Learn to be a bit of
a rudder for yourself.
And journal.
I still have stacks
of things that I
wrote across the years,
most of it is terrible,
but you will find if you go
back that you kind of knew
better all along even if you
didn't do better all along.
That voice in your
head, don't do that.
Do that.
This person's like
everyone else is
crazy about this
person but not me.
I don't want to
sound sentimental,
but you have to find your heart,
right, or at least not lose it.
You have to make
sure that you're
in touch with that piece
of yourself that wasn't
judging and just felt good.
And as long as
it's not something
that's self-destructive, I
think that's the most important
thing.
And then, yeah, have tools
and practices in place,
because they work,
and when you're 19,
and your neural neuroplasticity
is through the roof,
you can do a lot less
and get a lot more.
But don't worry about hitting
25 and it all being over.
Certainly, that's not the case.
But you can cram
in a lot early on.
I still regret not
learning an instrument.
The data on people that learn an
instrument even later in life,
but certainly at 19, is that it
greatly increases your ability
to learn all sorts of things.
So learn an instrument.
How can we transform the
American education system
to be more effective?
Oh, so in ten seconds.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
So when I'm in charge.
Nah, I'm just kidding.
A little while back,
I did an interview
with a major media outlet,
and they were very gracious.
And then they said,
like, what's next?
And I was like, I'm
going to run for office.
I was just like, look, it's
not out of the question.
But frankly, I think that I'm
so poorly suited for that,
it's obvious.
I'm so poorly suited for that.
So it wasn't a joke, but I think
as I spent some time afterwards
like, I should really
go talk to people
who do that for a living.
But I am very interested in
potentially informing policy.
If I were to ever be asked,
I'd certainly respond.
And my stance on this is much
in the same vein as the podcast,
because keep in mind,
the podcast, yes,
like suggested I start one, but
it was really during those days
of the deep 2020 and 2021
pandemic where, by the way,
I wasn't allowed to talk
about vaccines so I didn't.
And also, I don't have
any expertise in it,
so I was not well
suited to do it.
But I also decided it's a
topic that enough people are
talking about.
So my response in
life, and in general,
when people say, what
about something is I like,
well, I've got a lot
of opinions about that,
but this isn't the venue.
OK.
But during the
pandemic, I realized
there was a lot of circadian
disruption, anxiety, stress,
a bunch of things happening
with visual systems
and biological
systems that I felt
there were tools that people
could, perhaps, benefit from.
So I started putting that
information into the world,
and I was really
surprised, really
surprised that
people that I knew
from the neuroscience
community, for instance
at NIMH or in
government positions,
weren't talking about this
stuff, so I just kept doing it.
And I think that
it made clear to me
that the education
system is not one thing.
It's tough, especially when
talking about kids like what
to do is a tricky thing.
But that the education
system, in my mind,
should at least involve
some sort of discussion
early on about this
thing called the brain,
this thing called
the body, how they
work, how you can do certain
things to modulate your stress
level, your sleep not just
the importance of sleep
and nutrition and avoiding
social isolation and all
these important things, but
giving people some levers
and knobs to maneuver within
themselves and zero cost tools
as a way to do
that that transcend
socioeconomic boundaries,
ideally transcend language
as well, because we're not
just talking about the United
States.
And of course, within
the United States,
there are many
different cultures
speaking different languages.
And maybe AI will soon
allow us to put out
the podcast into a bunch
of different languages.
I think it will.
So I think the education system
should start, in my opinion,
with teaching kids how
to understand themselves,
what to do in difficult
scenarios that's really
anchored in the real pillars
of biology and psychology,
and take some of the
mystery out of trying
to navigate the tough
business of growing up.
I mean, if you think it's
tough being an adult, which
it can be, certainly.
It's really tough growing
up, as we all know.
And I think that more
tools, more tools,
more protocols more tools,
more tools, more protocols,
more tools.
But that's obviously
a biased opinion.
And no one's ever asked me
like, hey, what should we
be teaching kids?
But if they ask, as
you can tell, like,
I'm not going to shut up.
So I think that was
our last question.
Thank you all for
coming tonight.
forgive me for going long.
I do want to say
thank you, sincere
thank you for making your
way out here, especially
on a weekday night.
Thanks for your hospitality.
My incredible team,
I want to thank them.
And certainly,
last but not least,
thank you for your
interest in science.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]